one of the scenes we really wanted but
we did have to cut was a dressing room
scene
we wanted the girls to interact the way
a lot of us who have siblings and
sisters do when you share a room and
just borrow each other's stuff but we
found that once they were divided we
needed to keep them divided but we have
a little scene to show you we call the
dressing room scene that was just kind
of fun bit to yeah and i love girls
together what i love about it too is it
really was the beginning of finding
anna's personality though really that
quirky quirky fun goofy personality that
she's got so
yeah take a look
no no no no
calm yourself
control yourself
elsa
i'm here
i'm back
what happened to you pig pie i mean not
a pig pie but pig and pie and ocean
where is my rose dress still recovering
from the last time you wore it oh right
sorry please don't make a mess ooh
how about this
you are not wearing that to my
coronation
okay
hmm
what is this
my hips are here my hips are there oh
pardon my behind young man didn't mean
to knock you down
it was just a gift from whom i don't
know one of those big countries
stop goofing around i can barely fit
through the doorway